what the hell is time fall when you
first boot up death stranding you may
ask yourself this very question among
many many others however time fall and
weather play a huge role in death
stranding story and gameplay if you
aren't careful one bad time fall storm
can ruin an otherwise flawless delivery
here's a quick explainer on how to
survive death strandings weather system
and time fall time fall is basically
rain if rain eroded in deteriorated
objects at a much quicker pace anything
the time fall rain touches other than
raincoats for some reason will degrade
over time this applies to packages you
are carrying vehicles left out in the
rain equipment attached to your suit and
structures placed in the world early on
the best way to avoid time fall is to
find shelter in the form of caves
outposts and cities and wait out the
storm
when you rest in a safe house or private
room you will automatically pass time by
30 minutes unfortunately if you plan to
weather the storm outside you have to
wait in real-time most of the time this
is less than ideal especially if you are
doing a time delivery however there are
moments when time fall is unavoidable
one thing to consider in these scenarios
is how to load up your cargo packages
and boxes attached to the suit or
stacked above your backpack are more
exposed to time fall should there be a
storm on your journey a good rule of
thumb is to put important packages deep
in your backpack that way time fall
can't get to them as easily if you
notice that one of your containers is in
bad shape you can always repair it with
container repair spray this will fix up
the container but not its contents if
the cargo itself has been damaged
there's no way to repair it fortunately
during chapter 3 Sam will gain access to
some new tech that will make his life a
lot easier first is a weather forecast
built into his cuff links if you open
the map and click r3 twice you can see
the forecast for the next 30 minutes
once you've unlocked this avoiding time
fall storms becomes much easier in
Episode three you will also unlock a
time fall shelter using an upgraded PCC
you can create a giant umbrella that
protects Sam and his vehicle from
precipitation and even sprays out
container repair spray while you're
there better yet you can also advance
time by 10 minutes if you find yourself
in a storm that should end soon you can
always craft a time fall shelter and
wait it out keep in mind though that
some storms can last
very long time and the more you advance
time the sooner your other constructions
will deteriorate near the end of episode
3 there's also a character that gives
Sam a rain cover for his backpack that
will give your cargo an extra layer of
protection cargo degradation isn't the
only thing to worry about during a storm
when the rain turns black it means that
BTS are about to pay you a visit in most
cases especially early on the best thing
to do is to sneak by them this does mean
that your cargo will be exposed to rain
longer but that's better than it getting
scattered everywhere or worse destroyed
another good way to minimize your time
exposed to time fall is to use vehicles
trucks may not be able to protect your
cargo from reckless driving but they
will protect it from rain meanwhile
bikes may not offer as much protection
but you can speed right through storms
however if you try to speed through
black rain if BTS will stop you in your
tracks keep in mind that vehicles like
everything else deteriorate over time
due to time falls the last thing you
want is for your truck to break down in
the middle of nowhere with tons of cargo
in the back make sure to leave your
vehicles in a garage every now and then
to repair them and save often rain and
time fall isn't the only thing you
should look out for occasionally you and
Sam will have to contend with wind wind
is far less dangerous than rain but it
can drain your stamina quicker and make
it harder for Sam to find his footing
when his cargo is stacked high however
there is a more dangerous form of time
fall which takes the form of snow along
with forcing you to move slower it
degrades cargo even quicker
I'd recommend avoiding the snow as much
as possible until you have better
equipment to deal with it this is just a
basic rundown of how weather works in
death stranding and how you can prepare
for it keep in mind that this guide only
covers episodes 1 through 3 and some
more useful strategies will come into
play later in the game thanks for
watching and stay tuned to game spot for
more on deaths stranding
[Music]